let's get some reaction to what we've
just heard from
labour's shadow health secretary
jonathan
ashworth who joins us now
um mr ashworth uh
do you think that rob generic has a case
that
the chancellor and the prime minister
are they've been pinged and they
basically just have to do what they're
told
um and it's just unfortunate
i think there'll be parents across the
country
who have struggled this past year when
their
children have been sent home because
they were in a bubble and had to isolate
there will be workers across the country
who have to isolate when pinged
including in public services
like the nhs and i think for many of
them
waking up this morning to hear that
there is a
special rule an exclusive rule for boris
johnson
and rishi sunak they will be saying to
themselves
that this looks like one rule for them
and something else
for the rest of us nobody understands
how you can get
access to this special special treatment
this special vip lane
where you don't have to isolate yourself
if it is a pilot
why can't employers apply for the
workforce to be
members of this pilot why can't schools
have applied to be part of this pilot
test
i really do think a lot of people are
going to be looking at this and thinking
what on earth is going on and of course
this is a time when we need to maintain
confidence in the isolation policies
because isolation taking yourself away
from society
if you've been in contact with someone
who's got the virus is one of the key
ways in which we break transmission
and of course we know that infections
are rising at the moment
let's be uh fair here
if it were sakir stama in number 10
and you were the health secretary
you would be coming on here and saying
look the man is the prime minister
of course we have to take special steps
because uh
he runs the country and we can't have
the prime minister
uh inhibited from doing his job
i'm not sure how the prime minister
joining zoom calls from his office
in the flat above downing street
inhibits him doing his job to be frank
he's still able to use the telephone
he's still able to use
a computer and he's still able to join a
zoom call as
lots of us have had to do in these past
16 months
throughout the crisis i think why it
sticks in people's throat is that
apparently there is this special system
this vip system that you
that somehow some people can get on get
onto where they can avoid
isolating if they've been pinged now if
there is this system
then other people should be able to
apply for it other employers should be
able to apply for it and ask for their
workforce to be considered that's not
the case at the moment so for
so it looks like for a lot of us it is
indeed one rule for
them at the top and another for the rest
of us
okay well let's just talk about the
actual policy rather than the politics
of
this morning um there are a number of
things which are in the air
for example the proposal for test and
release
a version of it supported by your former
leader tony blair this morning i.e
that people who can can be tested every
day
and if they're negative they can get on
with their
jobs would you support that
being uh applied across the population
well sage are looking at it and i think
we should wait and see
for the sage final analysis of it of
course the problem with people getting
pings the problem with people being
asked to isolate is that is a symptom
of increased transmission in society now
we know that we've had over 50 000
cases we know that the virus is climbing
again
very steeply so what you've got to do is
put in
measures put measures in place to break
transmission chains but instead of doing
that we're about to have freedom day
tomorrow where the government where
sajid javid and others are effectively
putting their foot down on the
accelerator
and throwing off the seat belts because
precautionary measures
like mask wearing like encouraging
people to work from home like paying
people decent sick pay
are not being implemented i think that
is a mistake
this clear so when you and other labor
spokespeople have been saying
for the last two or three weeks you
don't oppose freedom day
what you really meant was that you do
oppose opening up on tomorrow
no we want to proceed with caution and i
would have an approach which
is about protecting what's due tomorrow
then
just to be clear what would you not do
tomorrow
well i would not get rid of the monetary
mass wearing look
people want people will want to uh do
the right thing and they'll want to wear
masks
but they want to be reassured that in
return that they are protected by others
wearing masks
but getting rid of the mandatory rule i
think is too much of a risk
tomorrow we're likely to see possibly
the busiest day on the transport
networks
for 16 months for people going back to
work i would say allow people to
continue to work from home
if they want to i would say let's let's
mobilize british manufacturing
to build air filtration units to put in
our schools and our premises
i would pay people sick pay and i will
prepare for the future
by investing in the national health
service now and because
we know
is pretty much what conservative
ministers come on here and say
so other than moving from mandatory
mask wearing to voluntary mask wearing
which
surveys in the last few days show us
that i think three quarters maybe more
of people will do anyway that's the
difference between
you and the government no and with
respect
i don't think it i haven't seen
conservative ministers coming on the
newspaper let me assure you you
obviously haven't watched a program but
that's what they've been saying pretty
much what you've just said
they don't talk about sick pay they
don't say they're going to fix sick pay
they don't say they're going to give
people the right to work from home
should they want to work from home they
don't say they're going to use
british manufacturing to build air
filtration systems to put them into
schools
and they're certainly not preparing the
future by investing in the nhs
or indeed looking at our testing
capacity and seeing if we can invest in
our testing capacity
to start testing for flu and other
respiratory viruses
this winter as well so there is actually
a difference between the labor party
and the conservative party of course our
proposals are backed up by sage
and indeed are backed up by a report
from the academy of medical sciences
last week the government's proposal is
to
is to just go full long into this
headlong into this throwing
a freedom day throwing off all
restrictions
that risks increased pressures on the
nhs and we're already seeing cancer
operations
cancelled even a liver transplant
operations cancelled uh in birmingham i
think it was
but it also risks a new variant
because when you have a pool of
infections in society and increasing
an increasing level of infection and you
have a partially
vaccinated population you're putting a
selection pressure on the virus
to mutate and the big risk is we could
snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory if you
like and be set back
uh set back and the vicious cycle starts
all over again
all right um i just want to keep seeing
you know what the labour party were in
government
would do differently um one other area
of policy where you might do something
different is on the uh
the pandemic if you like the pinocracy
there are those who say that we should
just drop the app
or that we should essentially tweak it
your former leader says this morning
that actually we need to adjust it so
fewer people
are pinged would you have it
desensitized or dropped
well again the problem with the pinging
isn't the ping in itself it's a
that is a symptom of transmission in
society and infection rates are
increasing which is why we would put in
place
those containment measures to slow the
spread
of the virus and that is a material
difference between us and the government
we would also by the way do more to
drive up vaccination rates amongst
younger people because we really need to
get younger people
uh to take part to take the vaccine and
of course
we would ask the speculation is the jcvi
are not going to propose
uh vaccination for adolescents we're
doing that in other countries
or they are doing it in other countries
in the united states in
in parts of europe and so on if that is
the advice from the jcpi then i suppose
that is the advice but i would really
ask them
to carefully consider whether or not we
should be vaccinating
uh teenage children in this country we
need to take another
a number of measures to really drive
infection rates down
stop people catching the viruses to stop
people being contacts of those
with the virus so just very briefly you
you are against vaccinating children
no no no i'm not against vaccinating
children i think it needs to be looked
at by
the jcpi if other countries are doing it
i don't understand why
we're not proposing it but of course in
the end these are always clinical
decisions
but if the jcvi are going to propose
tomorrow that
that we are that we should not vaccinate
children i hope they can fully explain
their thinking and why they've taken a
different decision to the united states
for example
thank you very much mr ashworth